hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
welcome back to winners on a wednesday
and in this video i am going to be
interviewing a very successful property
entrepreneur in coventry his name is
camille he's financially free he's left
his job quite recently and gone full
time into property and i thought i'd
pick his brain so that you can do the
same thing too so camille welcome so
much to winners on a wednesday welcome
thank you very much for having me well
you know what i've got so much respect
for you not just as a businessman but
also as a person you're a great man
you're a great dad you're a great friend
to me you're an asset to the academy and
it's just such an honor to open up my
doors in the house and to be able to
have this opportunity well thank you
very much it's a pleasure to be here to
be honest with you and it's great that
what we do is appreciated by our mentors
it's the best possible reward we can get
so where did this all start how did you
first get into property taught me
through the beginning and then i want to
pick your brain on how you've got these
deals i know you've got some very very
very profitable rent to rent but where
is this all how did this all start so it
started probably about about 12 months
ago
before that we bought with my wife to
buy gillette
and that's when i started to think that
there must be a quick way of getting
financially free bike lanes are great
but obviously it takes time to save the
deposit then obviously you know buy
another house set it up and then so on
so on so i thought there must be a
better way and this is when i came
across your videos and i was like okay
there are different strategies i want to
explore that and this is when i thought
okay i'm going to try with hmo and this
was the very first program i came across
and i bought your program
when i did it i was like more hungry for
more and then i then i started saying to
my wife look i need to buy something
extra i want to go we'll go further away
and i want to go for a full program and
this is when i said okay academy is
probably something for me because it's
not only going to be the programs itself
it's going to be
the the network and the people i'm going
to meet and this is what i wanted to do
so 12 months ago about 12 months ago it
was probably on the christmas eve when i
was on the on the phone with tommy group
he was actually sorting me out with all
the training programs and that's why i
joined the academy amazing so okay so
you previously were already a property
investor so you had two vital lengths
two vitality and the thing is as well
being a property investor if you do it
the traditional way which is as you say
save up money put a deposit down
number one it takes years for most
people to be able to save that kind of
deposit i mean the average house is a
quarter of a million pounds a deposit 25
you're talking about 62 000 pounds for
an average house
how long is that gonna take and then
when you buy it you've then got your
small little rent seven eight hundred
quid minus management maintenance voids
i mean you're not left with a fat lot so
you've got a couple of properties how
did you get the money to buy those
problems did you did you save up for
them how did you do that yeah so um we
bought our residential house back in
2015.
so we got some money through a national
appreciation of the values so we pulled
out some equity and we had some savings
and this is how we bought our first buy
to let a similar story with the second
house
we saved with some money
and that allowed us to buy a second buy
to let it was a process though it's our
first bike to that we bought in 2017 and
then the next house we bought in 2020 so
three days gap between one property and
another right um
as i say you know if we wanted to go
down that path it would take a long time
to actually build a portfolio that would
satisfy our our goals yeah and when you
say satisfy your goals what are you
doing about cash flow yes absolutely
cash flow so your job how much money
were you making in your job at this time
because clearly you must have been on a
reasonable salary to be able to save and
do what you said what kind of salary
would you want uh you know
but now the salary was uh roughly about
two grand okay a month uh it was a
reasonable salary it was a very good job
i was a production engineer in aerospace
business um i really didn't have
anything against the place the place was
absolutely okay they really allowed me
to to grow within the business i started
as a quality inspector i was just like
progressing i went to college in the
meantime so i've really you know
progressed my way through the company
and i was great uh but that obviously
didn't
wasn't taking me to where i wanted to be
my dream is not not to have to work i
won't have a choice rather than the uh
the duty to go somewhere and do
something for somebody else yeah and
you'll have old now
i'm 34 right now 34. so young guy
you're married
yes of course yes you avoid me for a
second you've got a beautiful son now as
well who's what's six uh he's five five
years old really nice really nice family
so
it must have been quite a big commitment
quitting your job which i know you did
quite recently how did you manage to get
the cash flow and the confidence
and the income to quit your job
okay so this is something i have to say
because the massive grassroots job goes
to my wife because i wouldn't be able to
achieve that without my wife
my wife is
working part-time but she's also running
her own business and at that point when
i started talking about
leaving my job uh we just you know did
all the you know
incomes and outcomes and we did that
proper balance in our thing yeah and we
worked out that this is just we are in a
position right now if i want to do it on
a full-time
as a full-time job being a property
entrepreneur i was like this is the time
so i either stay and where i am right
now and i'll probably carry on like that
to the end of my life or i quit my job
right now we have enough income from my
wife's business to cover our living
expenses uh and i can just focus on my
own business full-time so we gave myself
like about six months to see what the
results will be is beforehand i was
working full-time
and i tried to be
my first sort of idea to be like you
know in a property was to do
so i like deal selling
still selling however is a very active
task and obviously you have to be on a
phone you have to be you know
going from one estate agent to another
and i found that very difficult with my
full-time position and being like the
family guy as well
and this is where i started
recalibrating my uh my business and i
thought maybe instead of going like as a
deal seller i need to focus on the
rent's red business because this is
where i don't need to be so active on a
call and i can just you know do that
alongside my job
and um so at that point i was like
we have to do it like you know i'm
full-time but i'm not doing that at all
i know this is not what you teach
because you teach you know to to be a
little bit safe with your job and you
know we have some income before actually
quitting your job however i was in a
position that you know with my wife's
income we can we can focus on my
business as well so basically you went
all in because you joined the academy
which is a big investment
you quit your job which is a massive
sacrifice you put yourself in a
situation where it would make or break
and the reason i don't usually encourage
that is because it puts a lot of
pressure on me as a trainer because then
if the person isn't as successful as i
hoped and they've quit their job and
they've gone all so sometimes i'll try
and encourage people to just be a little
bit slow and steady yeah but you weren't
having any of it and you just went full
in
i had to because as i said i tried with
deal selling and that didn't work very
well i had like few deals i had i ended
up with one being worse and then
obviously i was just a lot of stress uh
at my job although i had my phone on me
i didn't want to like you know do two
things at the same time when i when i'm
at work i'm focused on my work and i
didn't have too much time to actually
focus on property entrepreneurship so i
was like i have to do it either 400 but
i don't do it at all because i made the
investment to the academy
he was just he was a no-brainer to me
yeah what was a no-brainer to quit your
job also to create my job and focus on
that hundred percent so question
now
fast forward six twelve months
are you making more money or less money
as you were in your job
i would say i will be making probably a
bit more money uh i'm definitely
financially free um i don't have to rely
on different bonuses as well you know
because i know this will be covering my
full expenses i've completely replaced
my income
as we speak i've got 21 groups right now
because i'm focusing on rent hmos
19 groups are already occupied
so uh i've got two rooms available uh
with people just you know convenient for
them so i'm hoping by christmas all my
rooms will be fully occupied and that
will give me like you know a complete
replacement of my salary there's a
couple of hundred more probably great
and in terms of time-wise and i know we
spoke about this with rental rents it is
recurring deal sourcing every time you
want to get paid you have to sell a deal
whereas with rent to rent you get a
property and you can systemize it how
many hours a week in say january moving
forward what's the properties fully
fully rented you've got pretty much
there how many hours a week do you think
you have to personally spend
managing the the
portfolio i'll probably say
four five six hours i would say on
average um
i will definitely be going to to do the
safety checks which is obviously
mandatory thing that i have to do
obviously a bit of admin
and making sure that the properties are
okay you know just general inspections
really yeah so once the properties have
fully tenanted if i don't have to find
another tenant i think on average it's
gonna be probably about four or five
hours a week so that's not that's about
half a day a week so the question is if
you're making as much money or even more
money than you were before but you're
only working at this very fraction of
the time what are you going to do with
the rest of your time that's a good
question because obviously i want to
expand obviously rent rentals is the
very first step on my property journey
right now
i want to focus on more advanced
strategies like brr and flips and
obviously rent rent is just the very
first station where obviously it gives
me that cash flow yeah so i obviously
covered my salary now i'm gonna be
focusing on building my own portfolio as
well that's amazing because sometimes
people think that when they become
financially free and make two three
thousand pounds a month in recurring
capacity income property income they
think that they will just lie on a beach
and do nothing but actually that's just
phase one you know phase one is
replacing your income phase one is
becoming financially free the next phase
is building up wealth security leaving
generational legacies and wealth for you
for your family setting up charities and
really making a big impact and that's
kind of now you're moving towards that
stage which is really exciting so to
people watching this video they might be
in a situation whereby they haven't got
to stage one yet they might not even
have got their first deal yet so talk me
through um how did you get your first
deal what happened how did that come
about yeah of course so obviously after
um when i was like on my notice period
at my work
i had my very first deal in a pipeline
um so i knew that by the time i'm
quitting my job i'm going to get key to
that property and i'm going to be like
you know renting it out as a first
property unfortunately two days before i
actually got the keys the number rang me
and he said that he checked his terms
and conditions with the uh with the
lender and that didn't allow um any any
kind of you know i just letting or like
this advanced management sort of thing
so he said that he's not comfortable
with proceeding
so when i was leaving my job i didn't
have anything
uh
what month was this this was in july wow
that was in july so six months ago by
six months ago absolutely um so i just
went back to uh to my book and obviously
i was just starting from scratch you
know following the same process because
it is a process at the end of the day
yeah so i just i was ringing i was
calling sending messages and all that i
was just like religiously doing that
every single day um
my wife was laughing at hey yes at some
point because i was getting up in the
morning i was doing my daily routine and
i was just like dressing up like i was
going to work like you know in the
shirts and stuff like that i was sitting
by the desk because ultimately
i respected that this is my full-time
job right now
so if i treat it seriously obviously now
it's going to pay me off right so that's
what i did and i was religiously doing
that every single day and i had many
many notes before i got my first yes uh
hamilton how many knows to be honest i
wouldn't be able to tell you definitely
more than
100 oh wow
it definitely felt like more than 100 as
well
because unless you're tracking it it's
hard to know yeah because you can get
rejected five times and it can feel like
50 times as well yeah maybe maybe you
genuinely did get rejected 100 times
and what were they saying so who are you
getting rejected by and what when you
say rejected was it like let me take the
details i'll give you a call back if
we've got anything interesting or is it
more like
f we don't do that you know how bad was
the rejection uh it wasn't too bad to be
honest with you most of the time it was
either i was sorry we don't do that or
sorry but the figure is not uh not
satisfactory or uh we do that ourselves
you know i had like few other people who
said that they're doing exactly the same
business model so it was generally not
too bad but it was still a note but i
understood that this is like a part of
the process yeah first go for no and if
you say that in the training go for now
and i was going for that no because i
knew that every single note takes me
closer to that yes yeah yeah it's really
interesting you say that it's a process
because a lot of people say to me i'm
just starting my property journey and
you know what i say to that i'll say
it's not a journey it's a process and if
you follow the process you will get to
the result that you need because two
plus two is four and in the same way if
you say this script to these people
enough times you will get the results
it's uh if there's no ifs and buts about
it it will happen in case of when so
okay so that first deal fell through
because the landlord said that there was
a restriction on the lender which is
actually quite a common thing yeah and
you know it says in the contract that it
is the landlord's responsibility to
ensure that there's no restrictions to
doing short lets or uh multiple uh
household block you could say on the
property so just talk a little bit more
about what that means and also how did
you overcome that in the future did that
ever come back as a formula a little bit
more about that sure of course so with
this particular landlord everything
seems to be okay to be to be honest with
you always it was a little bit
disappointing
um
i felt like this was the right time
because if i got the keys and we already
started the contract ongoing um and then
he would say that something is not right
on the lender's side would have to
terminate the contract which would
obviously incur some cost so i could
make a loss yeah and it was a good
lesson for me definitely because then
when i started approaching different
languages and when landlords were like
happy with it i was just like letting
them know that this is their
responsibility to check if lending is
okay and they haven't got any other
restrictions because it's on their side
and obviously i can't be responsible if
they find out a little bit later
um
and also before signing anything i was
just sending them a draft contract yeah
so i was just like showing them this
these are my types of conditions and
read it
had to think about that because
obviously it's going to be buying you
for like three four five years so it's
very important that you understand what
you're signing and make sure that
you're okay with it i'm okay with it and
this is where we can just you know make
a business together that's great so
basically you took the lesson from it
and sometimes experience is the best
teacher i mean on the academy that's why
when we train you it's not just
theoretical we also get you doing live
calls on the program uh so that you're
learning as you're doing yeah of course
i mean this is what i love about the
training to be honest with you because
it's not just about sitting there for
like two or three days and listening to
your mentors it's all about you know
seeing them how they do it live and then
you actually walk away and you do it
yourself yeah so there were actually
people in the room on the day when they
were like saying that they've got
viewings booked they've got deals booked
and it was it was absolutely incredible
because if you were like room full of
like people 50 60 people
and all of them are sharing something
then
you're pro you're absorbing it it's it's
and that's the beauty of the of the
academy and of the live events because
it just becomes part of you as well it's
almost like positive peer pressure
everyone everyone's doing together
because you know you've been on the
academy night you've now done about a
year about about a year into the academy
but
everybody else that was part of your
group they're also doing deals
financially free it's the norm it's not
like you're the star people and
you know it's just normal absolutely
it's absolutely normal i mean you know
that that's that's the beauty of it
they're not accidental people people who
pay that much money they commit to
something that's why
this room is full of people that want to
get to something and that's a beautiful
thing obviously when you're approached
by those those same people entertain
that same group
if even if you wanted to be lazy it's
impossible yeah because they affect you
with their activeness and how they
active so if you want to become the same
yeah
so your first deal fell through just
before two days before you got the keys
which was really disappointing you told
me you were saying all right you kept
this house quiet and that's because uh
you've probably heard me say before
never be at ease until you got the keys
so your deal fell through two days
before you got the gears which could
happen so your next deal then how how
quickly after how soon after that did
you get your next deal um so i got the
keys to the next property
on the 12th of august to literally just
a couple of few weeks yeah exactly
so
as i say because i was you know treating
that as a full-time job and i was
treating that very seriously i wanted to
as i said you know we had like six
months so i had the time to prove that
it's actually something that i can do so
i really didn't didn't have time to
actually know uh to lose to waste so i
was just like actively looking for deals
this particular deal that i found
i messaged a very nice lady
so
similar kind of thing i went and did the
viewing um and i said to her from the
very beginning i told them about my
business model
um and i said obviously i'm not going to
be paying as much as they get from like
a typical management company but at the
same time my service level is much
better because i'm offering like big
threats and i'm getting like you know
i've got making this tv plays which i've
i talked about before i built a in my
opinion a nice website as well i did
that myself so they could refer back to
it and see what we do you know we've got
all the clients sorted as well so we are
like fully legit business and this is
what we offer and she said that she's
managing this property on behalf of the
landlord but she's built like many other
properties so she's happy to have that
property on to me and she was happy with
the figure along with the landlord so i
said okay so when can we make that deal
happen
and she was like pretty much straight
away i was like okay so i'm happy with
it i'm happy to pay deposited the
property was absolutely immaculate it
was just in such a great condition that
i didn't have to pay even like you know
a single penny to actually you know
refer the property i wanted to have it
as my first one and that was just like
my little pill you know so and and
that's how it happened i think that's
one of the very good things that i
learned from the academy as well be a
man of your word so if you say to them
to the landlord whoever you talk to that
you're going to be paying deposit or to
play that do it do it as you say how
much money did you have to pay to get
the keys in your hand how much it was
just above 700
1700 and on average is that about normal
what kind of money do you normally i
know your latest one up which i won't
man you didn't pay anything i didn't pay
anything yet i've paid now
but how did you structure that so how
did you manage to pay nothing to begin
with and why was that so clever
so
with this last property that you could
see um it was actually quite a story
because it was i literally picked the
nicki's from the builders so when we
agreed with the number of the terms and
conditions i was meant to pick up the
keys like three weeks earlier uh
unfortunately the builders were a little
bit late with their jobs and
they had to finish up the snagging and
stuff
so the landlord said that he's
absolutely happy for me to have the keys
and i could conduct some viewings
however we wouldn't be able to uh to
moving tenants until the certain time
because there was still snagging going
on
um so i said okay how about i'll pay you
when i move in my first tenant and he
thought that's fair i thought it's fair
and that's how it happened so obviously
when you came and viewed the property at
that point i didn't have any tenants yet
but i had the keys so i was doing my
business although i didn't pay anything
upfront yet so during that snagging
process you were doing viewings on the
property yeah selling the rooms yeah and
then meanwhile
you you then end up paying the landlord
from the money you got from the tenants
yeah pretty much that some of the money
i i paid
to the landlord was pretty much coming
from the
that's crazy and that's the thing so
that was effectively a no money down
deal yeah you can say that and you've
got four rent to rent now yeah um how do
you know whether a rent to rent is a
good deal what are the formulas
um how much money should you be making
from a rent to rent how much return on
investment should you be getting what
are the formulas uh so in my opinion
that this is obviously my my personal
sort of goal to achieve minimum of 500
pounds for from renter and deal yeah
this is something that you obviously
teach and i remember that from my trend
intensive yeah you said minimum 500
pounds this is what we should be aiming
at and that's what i'm doing and i'm
trying to be super conservative with my
numbers as well when it comes to like
calculating the bills calculating the
council and things like that i try to
sort of you know be on their right side
rather than wrong side i prefer to make
more money accidentally rather than you
know make less money because they didn't
take that into account in the first
place yeah so that's not that's my
absolute minimum that's why you say with
the four properties together you should
be making a minimum of two thousand
pounds hey if it's more if it's two five
or three amazing but you've worked out
your numbers sort of worst case scenario
and the thing is the reason that we do
that is because
sometimes it's easy to be too optimistic
you you almost
you look at the best case oh i'm sure i
could do that but then actually if
you're doing a rental rent and you're
only making 200 pounds a month it's
sometimes it's not worth the hassle and
or especially if you have to put money
down up front if you have to put down a
couple of thousand pounds and you're
only making 200 pounds a month it's
gonna take you a year before you can
actually get almost before you actually
get your money back so it's really
important that you do the formulas right
because a good deal is amazing but
sometimes people are so desperate to get
a rent to rent a deal that they take on
bad deals and they don't make enough
money in my opinion i mean that's just
something that i've seen from amateurs
what would be your biggest learning
point from all this whole experience of
the academy of becoming financially free
what's the biggest lessons that you
learned
there are so many of them
but i would say the message to people
today is probably
training is is it must you know you have
to go and you need to do the training uh
you can't just pretend that you're like
like a super pro rent to renter without
taking the training it's the first thing
another thing is if you're not prepared
to change your mindset it's not going to
work out as well because training is
great you're going to end up with having
a lot of knowledge contracts and stuff
like that but if you're not prepared to
change your mindset and believe in
yourself then that training will also go
in vain um so my my advice is change
your mindset change your belief
and think that the others can do it i
can do it as well yeah that's great so
important to get to not only have the
training and the knowledge but also the
belief because otherwise you'll be
hearing or what you can do and here's
how you do it if you're just thinking oh
i don't believe it's too good to be true
yeah whatever then it's not going to
happen because if you say actually i'm
gonna i'm gonna have to believe to take
action and implement that's where it
happens and you've done really well at
doing that and quitting your job and
going out implementing what does your
wife think now of your success she's
like you know she's super happy with it
to be honest you know every morning we
just you know wake up and we just say
let's go for more let's go for more so
we just motivate ourselves as i said
she's also running her own business so
we try to keep the mindset very positive
and i think we're getting better and
better at it um it's almost like you
know planting the seed you have to
really you know make sure that it's
growing so you need to water it and you
need to look after it and and every day
i'm listening to like you know
motivational speeches i do like you know
i've got my daily routine so obviously i
set my data right in the right path yeah
and i i would say this is another tip
for others you know just set up your
daily routine and and surround yourself
with people who are like cheering you up
and celebrating success with you because
you need to celebrate every little thing
that you achieve in your life what
advice would you give to somebody that
was around the wrong people their
friends their family weren't encouraging
them in the way that your wife
encouraged you the support that you had
the because you've got so many friends
with people that are
killing it in property someone that's
saying how do i get around those people
how do i get that sort of support yeah
what would you say i say um
if you're surrounded by people who don't
support you they are not the right
people in your life because ultimately
they will stop and block you from
chilling where you want to be you want
to put yourself around people who are
like you know successful in other areas
and if you want to be a property
entrepreneur you want to be a rent to
renter find people like that and
obviously by joining courses and joining
the academy that helped me to gain not
only like other property entrepreneurs
but now i can call those people friends
we are in touch like every single day if
i've got a problem i definitely know i
can reach out to them they can we can do
like a brainstorm session and see if
that's not gonna work for me
so really it's about getting into the
right
group of people and
also i would say you know very important
thing is to have like a mentor academy
also gives you the opportunity to have
like one-to-one mentoring calls which is
absolutely brilliant and i want to give
like massive shout out to like your mum
sue she was actually great because we
had so many good quotes and she's so bad
and so knowledgeable about different
things for people like anthony day and
tony crook you know they're absolutely
superstars you know tony crook for
example he helped me with my business
plan he's very good business person so
when i was like you know treating me
seriously i was i was doing things step
by step and i wanted to have like a
business plan and action you know where
i'm going to be six months twelve months
so much time yeah and tony was super
helpful with that as well you know so he
had a look at the end of my business
plan and he then gave me some tips he
told me what was very good what i could
improve on
so yeah having having mentors alongside
your friends and property people who are
on the same journey with you or some
process and then then yes
you're definitely going in the right
direction so important to other people
mentors but also success buddies
people you can bounce off on them again
on the academy you write like all my
mentors my mom who's a mentor to me tony
crook who's my business penta all my
mentors i've pulled them in onto the
academy and uh you know it's such a such
a busy place you've been a real asset
and that's your question final question
so what is your strongest reason for
doing all this what's the you must have
had a big reason to something that was
deep to quit your job to go full time
into property you've got a son i mean
what is the strongest reason why for you
i'm not gonna be super original here to
be honest with you because my wife is my
family so obviously i've got a five year
old boy i've got my wife and i want us
to be financially free i want us to have
a choice
and that is my why um
but also
one of the inspirations i have actually
from your book uh and from your history
was obviously when you went to africa
and i'd line up your story that you
broke your leg and obviously you were
there building some wells and you know
you were in the african villages
that really was super strong for me uh i
would like to help other people as well
so when i have my financial freedom and
i'm on a certain level in my life and i
know i don't have to worry about my my
cash flow and my future i can then focus
on helping other people yeah that's what
i like to do
so these are my strongest wise you know
my family but also helping other people
who really need help
and that's also i would like to inspire
people today when you're thinking about
starting something bigger in your life
don't just think about yourself think
about others so one change in your one
life can make so many changes in other
people's lives yeah that that's what i
believe should be like you know a driver
for many of the
that's amazing well honestly it's been
such a pleasure thank you very much for
coming to be interviewed uh if you're
watching this at home and you enjoy the
video do us a favor
just hit the like button drop a nice
comment below don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and if you like camille
if you want to come down to some of the
training and experience it firsthand for
yourself i've got good news for you i am
giving away free tickets right now to
the property investors crash course we
have got limited spaces so i'm going to
leave a link below get down now book
your place and i look forward to working
with you and helping you achieve
financial freedom too see you soon